hey guys it's greg here I just got done
watching Jack Reacher never go back and
now it's 1030 and night and I'm going in
and out because [ __ ] you I'm hungry oh
my god damn burger right now don't judge
[ __ ] stop [ __ ] judging me
anyway I'm getting gian almost called
him Jerry I'm getting John to watch this
movie I haven't told him yet that I need
him to watch this film so I can have a
review with him up by this weekend I was
going to just do it alone but let me
give you a little quick review of the
film it is the worse film they're seeing
all be here I mean I'm sure there's
other films that have come out that are
probably worse but out of the films I've
gone to to see in the actual movie
theaters this is without a doubt the
worst film I've seen all year and I need
John there would be a passion honestly
this is such an awful film oh man and I
I just I can't believe it like Tom
Cruise you're my homeboy dude I have
loved and supported you when you were
jumping on couches man and going all
Scientology rants and yeah I like I just
I have always loved you and this is the
first time in a long time I'm like whoa
you let me down how do you have the high
hopes for this film there was just it
was a really just up there is like close
to zero redeeming qualities like out of
I don't I mean like there might be films
out there that have a lower percentage
score that I've reviewed that I didn't
move and the film they didn't like but I
can still say like there are films out
there that i saw that i did not like but
there are still redeeming qualities in
there this film has just zip I wasn't
even like the biggest Jack Reed
fan of the first one if I really admired
and respected it so to see a film that
doesn't do any of the good things from
the first one and adds horrible just
writing and terrible direction the
action is not even cool like that was
the one thing that could have gotten
right with some cool action but uh yeah
yeah I know millions of dollars went
into this and a lot of people worked on
that film but do you dennis is not a
good movie